Anderson Cooper and Andy Cohen do you
mean oh yeah your relationship with
Anderson is there a relationship with
Anderson Cooper because you guys were
tight I know I'm you really tacked
together I loved him like I really loved
him and I loved doing that show I mean
we only did it once you know one night a
year so when Donald Trump jr. Eddie
Munsters I lovingly call him when he
demanded that CNN you know fire me I'm
not an employee at CNN I go around the
world and I tell jokes and then when
they did fire me and then he tweeted
again no she should be banned and then
they did so you're talking to so he's
been for life from CNN and that's just
weird
and so the Anderson part I don't even
have a joke for it because not honestly
that was just her sure and it's that
feeling of it was such a dog pile such a
dog pile and some people were actually
calling me even on that day just say oh
I can't be associated with you anymore
people that know me you know and then
you know of course I had some foes
calling like you had this comment girl
and stuff and part of it is a product of
me being a very how should I say
in-your-face comedian or yeah and some
of it is look let me tell you something
when you're a 57 year old female honey
I've been me tuned and times up like you
can't imagine so sometimes there's even
a little bit of a resentment like who do
you think you are being a 57 year old
woman being in this business and being
successful so that's one of the reasons
I was determined to just fight my way
back no matter how many jokes I had to
write it no money Howie people call me
names and I'm so grateful to just get
back to doing my job and people are sort
of moving on in their own way I know
that Andy Cohen had said that he was
waving the white flag with with you
they'd had it was your interpretation of
that and well I mean I just think Andy
Cohen is like kind of ridiculous I mean
first of all you know I've been in
television for a long time I have two
Emmys two more than the president whoa
you know Andy Cohen was my boss at Bravo
for years yeah he was honestly a
miserable boss okay and so what's
unusual is you have this guy who's an
executive at a network and for the first
time in television gives himself a
nightly talk show cancels me you know
and I did a bunch of specials there I
they never did specials before I did
them there so you guys are never
super tight but I know he kind of had it
in for me in the way that now that it's
like game on Cathy yeah he's just keeps
going and coming for me and all this
other stuff so he's just doing his thing
and he my opinion of him is he's just
someone who's you know his his level of
talent is diminished by his lack of
ability Wow okay that's one way to put
it when it comes to material for this
obviously that whole situation is a
wealth of material it is but when you
start dealing with other parts of your
life like are the Kardashians your
neighbors is that the deal yeah why
what's unusual about that they're
neighbors how are they not everyone
hears neighbors I mean they're just
multiplying like Rapids right so how
about I mean through all this yeah to be
next door to Kim kardashian-west and
Kanye Kardashian West who's a free
thinker and remember like when he went
to Trump Tower with the blonde Mohawk
and so I went next door and I'm like
what the hell is going on right you know
believe it or not I've really turned a
corner on the Kardashians and here's why
sure they may be a little shallow and
materialistic but at least they're not
trying to actively kill me right and
this year today we can get along just
fine but when you see Kanye say that
some of the stuff that he has in the
last couple of weeks are you like oh man
oh yeah yeah oh yeah that goes I've seen
it I've seen it there was one time that
I just have to tell you that I never
thought first of all wouldn't didn't
think I would be living next to them but
one time their mom Kris Jenner who
ironically came over to my house the
night of the photo with Academy Award
nominee Melanie Griffith from working
girl and we had had this dinner plan for
about a month and the picture comes out
and they come over and I'm sobbing and
I'm a wreck and they were they were so
perfect because Kris kept saying just
apologize we do it all the time just
apologize and Melanie Griffith's was the
little devil and my shoulder saying do
with Mike Pence tomorrow do it bigger
and Kris is like no no that's bad for
business on the guy so so much crazy it
is but right you're laughing yeah so
there you go so that's my job is this
somehow turn this into something funny
and even relatable because honestly the
United States we are living in the
upside down from that show stranger
things it is so crazy that
just want to tell everyone in Canada
just stay here do you change your show
when you come here yes yeah of course I
do
first of all I I think you guys should
get extra security for Prime Minister
Trudeau because if Ivanka shows up she's
got her eyes on him but but I mean big
time also I think Melanie would go for
it yeah the first lady Melanie so I
would keep you know the Prime Minister
under lock and key at least till the
Trump's are in prison yeah soon and how
are the audience's do they I mean with
you there well remember I haven't done
one single American show yet remember I
still can't even get any paid work in my
own country so why is like a Shawn baby
I'm John black listen yes it is it is
Jericho over time for me and Hollywood
I'm sorry and probably but he won't like
when I say that but I want to be honest
about it but nobody has stepped up
nobody nothing no and that's the part
that kills me is like I love the
thoughts and prayers
you don't like every tragedy thoughts
and furniture but no I got to do one TV
appearance on Comedy Central on the
president's show and this guy Anthony
who plays the president plays him so
well and he let me play Kellyanne Conway
for one episode and I was almost crying
because I said Anthony do you know that
in a year you and I've never even met
him I said you're the only person in
this whole country who's lifted a finger
and what I mean by that where was you
know lots of people were sort of saying
like oh you were kind of getting screwed
over but I can't tell you how many
charity gigs I've shown up for and
performed at this person's event and
that one and then when this happened
they all scattered like cockroaches on
the like lights came out off the record
with people are you asking them why and
are they being honest yeah sometimes
honestly it's really hard for me to ask
because it's embarrassing
like course to call someone you know to
call like Judd Apatow or JJ Abrams or
you know guys that I know but I don't
think of them necessarily in a work
context or I don't think of someone that
I would be like hitting up for a job you
know I'm also like kind of a stab like I
don't mean to sound like an idiot but
I've got like two Emmys and a Grammy and
nothing like yeah and so it's not like
people don't sort of know what I do kind
of and so some people like straight up
said can you help me and mostly I found
they just didn't they kind of wanted to
gossip and they wanted to hear like the
fun juicy parts of the story and the
two-month federal investigate
and the interrogation and by the way I
go into the interrogation in my live
shows I can't resist because it really
is the elephant in the room yeah and you
just have to try to picture me being
interrogated by two federal agencies I
mean I'm not exactly unfiltered so it's
kind of amazing I'm not you know in
cuffs right now